hey y'all welcome to my flickers of fear
movie review show
let's talk about dean koontz for a
minute because
i kind of feel like after stephen king
uh dean koontz is kind of like you know
your big best-selling horror author he
sells you know a [ __ ] ton of books and
sells i think almost as many as stephen
king does and he's actually been writing
for longer than stephen king i think he
first started publishing books in the
late 60s uh where stephen king started
in the early 70s so you know he's got
like a prodigious output
but the strange thing about that is that
despite his popularity and despite how
many books he's put out it really
doesn't seem like there's been a [ __ ]
ton of film adaptations of his work
there have been some
but
not as many as you would think and
obviously not as many as stephen king
has which is like stephen king's
adaptations just like every there's like
hundreds of them probably at this point
but dean koontz adaptations not so much
and the ones that they make
tend not to be all that great i kind of
feel like
prior to this one i think like the best
one was probably demon seed from 1977
which we reviewed like a long time ago
that was actually uh pretty damn good
and watchers from the 80s like 1988 i
think that came out with corey haim that
was kind of fun it's kind of very 80s
and very goofy but that was like pretty
good but some of the other ones
um just seem like they're really kind of
forgettable or just kind of
terrible you know uh which like i said i
think it's really interesting not only
because he's so popular but i've only
read probably one or two of his books
maybe more than that like over the years
and i get the sense that his writing
style
is very cinematic so you would think
that it would lend itself really well to
the film medium and yet
uh there really aren't that many that
and you know even the ones that are out
there just really aren't all that
noticed honestly because when i looked
up like the list of all the movies of uh
that had been made of dean koontz's
books it's like i haven't even seen most
of them or heard of most of them so it
seemed like they didn't really
do any big business or anything like
that
however uh back in 2011
you got stephen summers now we've talked
about him before because he is the uh
writer director behind
massive hits like the mummy and the
mummy returns uh he also did van helsing
back in 2004
and he also did the very underrated and
quite cool monster movie from 1998 deep
rising which i reviewed on this series
like not too long ago
so
he wanted to adapt dean koontz's
2003 best-selling novel odd thomas
uh to a movie
now the book was a massive success
and
following that success it actually ended
up spanning like a huge series it was
like six
sequels
there were three
prequels which i think were also graphic
novels and then there was a couple other
novellas which were sort of like i don't
know if they were necessarily like off
you know like offshoots or something
like that but they were just kind of
like other like standalone adventures so
this is like a massive massive series
the autonomous series and um you know
they all kind of feature the titular
character whose name is thomas
now uh i will say that of all the dean
coons adaptations i've seen which is not
a lot admittedly this one is pretty
[ __ ] good so i don't think anyone
will probably argue with me all that
much
that
as far as now
uh this is probably the best dean koontz
adaptation by a very very significant
margin because this movie is pretty
[ __ ] good
now the movie was actually finished in
2011
but then there were a bunch of legal
problems like with the production
company i don't know exactly like what
all the wrangling was all about but the
upshot of it was that the movie kind of
like sat on a shelf for two years so it
wasn't released until 2013.
and even then it got like a really
half-assed release it's sort of like
snuck into theaters for like a minute
and
nobody saw it nobody talked about it
nothing and even though it cost 27
million dollars to make it made less
than 2 million back
so
i kind of feel like maybe after anton
yelchin died in 2016 in like a [ __ ]
freaky ass accident like where his own
suv like rolled over on him and like
crushed him it's like it was horrible uh
you know and he was only like i think he
was only 27 when he died
so when he died in 2016 i think that
this movie got like a little bit more
recognition just because people were
going back and you know looking at his
uh filmography up to that point
but really it just seems like
just people don't really talk about it
even though there's like all these big
names behind it um you know like steven
summers who's like a massive director
and dean cones who's like a massive
horror writer and it just kind of seems
like nobody really talks about it and
that's really a shame because this is
actually a really fun and also kind of
like emotionally wrenching like a very
like a heartfelt type of movie but it's
just like a fun rollercoaster type ride
it's got like really cool special
effects and [ __ ] like that maybe i don't
know i'll get into it a little bit later
but maybe like the tone of it like was
weird for people i'm not really sure but
i'll get into that a little bit later so
anton yelchin plays the title character
whose name is odd thomas and he kind of
explains at the beginning uh that oh
well my mom said that she was supposed
to name me todd but they messed it up on
the birth certificate or whatever so it
was just like so i don't know but that's
his first name his first name is odd
uh so he's kind of this lovable 20
something uh year old guy
and he's working as a fry cook in uh
this little sort of diner in this small
town called pico mundo which is like in
the american southwest and was like in
new mexico i think it is
now odd has a pretty uh simple existence
he keeps things minimal he doesn't have
a car he doesn't have you know anything
he says in the beginning i don't own a
house i don't own anything
because i want to keep everything like
as simple as possible
uh but he does have a girlfriend who uh
he loves more than life itself and her
name is bronwyn llewellyn although she's
better known as stormy that's how she's
always uh
known
so the two of them have known each other
since they were kids and they kind of do
like all these flashbacks where they got
this little card from one of those
carnival fortune teller things and it
said you'll be together forever and they
actually like believe that so they are
very much in love with each other now
stormy works at the mall and she works
like in an ice cream shop so she manages
an ice cream shop or something like that
so odd though uh has a very strange gift
much like cole in the sixth sense he can
see dead people significantly unlike
cole odd usually
when he sees people who come to like
dead people come to him for help and he
will actually go and try to like unravel
the mystery and he'll actually like go
kick someone's ass if an ass needs
kicking you know what i mean so he's
kind of like trained and fighting and
stuff like not it's not like ninja or
anything like that but he can hold his
own if he has to
uh for example at the beginning of the
movie like to establish this
he's visited by this little girl you
know you you don't know she's a ghost at
first but he's kind of like talking in
narration
this little girl comes to him and she
the dead people don't talk that's one
thing in the movies which i kind of
liked um he said he can see them and
they can gesture and they can kind of
give him psychic visions like by
touching him and stuff but they don't
they can't talk so this little girl
comes to him and she was murdered and
the guy that killed her uh is a local
and odd knows him
so once he finds out like who it is he
actually like uh
gives chase to the guy like beats the
[ __ ] out of him and then you know he
makes sure like the cops come and
uh they find evidence and stuff like
that so he gets arrested and put away
now happily for odd uh the chief of
police of the town who is played rather
delightfully by willem dafoe knows all
about odds psychic gift he knows he can
see dead people and because every single
thing that odd has told him has happened
like exactly the way he said so he
actually does believe it and he takes
him seriously and
he's also like
they're also friends so
he'll always kind of like finagle things
you know like when this
child killer gets collared uh you know
he's like oh well we'll just say that
you saw the pictures of the dead girl in
his car and like you just you know what
i mean so he's kind of trying to make it
so that other people don't find out
about his gift you know what i mean so
he's always kind of like trying to
engineer behind the scenes so he doesn't
uh get found out
now not too long into the movie
odd starts to sense that
something really really big and really
really bad is going to happen in the
town
because mostly
recently he's been seeing a bunch more
of these things he calls them bodaks
uh they're kind of these weird demony
sort of creatures they kind of come out
of the earth they're sort of clear but
they're kind of like look like monsters
and they like kind of climb all over the
walls and ceilings and stuff they
actually feed on human suffering and
misery uh bodaks i looked up because i
was like looking up on the wikipedia
page i'm like oh that's a real thing i
guess it's a real thing and well it's
not a real thing obviously but uh it's a
thing in gaelic folklore although
they're not usually like seen as demons
they're more like well i guess they're
sort of seen as like boogeymen type
things or like tricks or spirits kind of
things so that's what he calls them
bodax
now the boat acts
don't
cause bad things to happen
but you know that something really bad's
gonna happen when they
you know when you see a bunch of them
because
they're like getting ready to feast on
this big massive because he's like if
it's just you know he's like if it's
just like one person getting murdered
he's like you know that's bad but
that doesn't draw them in it has to be
like a big huge [ __ ] deal where
there's like a lot of human suffering
and then they'll come out
and like start uh you know getting ready
to like feed on it right
so
he knows that something really really
terrible is gonna happen
and uh you know he's going around the
town and he just sees them all over the
place which means that a bunch of people
in the town are gonna die soon
now nobody can see the bodax but him
obviously because he's a psychic and he
can see dead people and interdimensional
beings or whatever but significantly the
bodaks he has to pretend that he can't
see them because if they realize that
they can see him
then they'll kill him so sometimes like
he'll be like there'll be scenes where
he's like in a diner and he just sees
the bodaks like climbing all over all
these people and stuff like that and he
just has to like act all natural like he
doesn't see what he sees you know what i
mean because if they recognize that he
sees them then he's in big trouble so
there's not only that he already sees
all these like demon things like
crawling around
um but he also has this really weird
like dream vision type situation where
he's like in an alley and then he sees
all of these people that are wearing um
like red and black like bowling shirts
and he sees them all getting shot and
none of them have any faces and they're
all like grabbing him like help us help
us and he's just like what the [ __ ] was
that all about like he doesn't have any
idea
what it's all about and then he finds
out like his co-worker uh vi
she also had a nightmare where she got
shot and like she looked over and saw
somebody else lying next to her that
also had a red and black bowling shirt
on so he's like okay well obviously this
is has to do with like whatever the big
bad thing is going to happen
so
odd knows that something really really
terrible really awful is coming down the
pipe but he doesn't know exactly
what it is or exactly when it's going to
happen
so basically the movie is him trying to
like piece together
the mystery so he can prevent whatever
is going to happen is going to happen
because he knows it's going to be awful
and like a lot of people are going to
die
now the first thing he sees there's this
guy he sees at the restaurant where he
works and he calls him he has this
really weird hair it's kind of like
i can't really explain it but it's just
sort of like normal color at the top but
then it has like a blonde cap i think
like stormi at one point says it looks
like a yellow yarmulke yamaka so yeah so
it looks like that but it's like it kind
of looks like
he said it was like a weird like yellowy
moldy color so they start calling him
fungus bob
but he sees fungus bob in the restaurant
and he notices that the bodaks are like
crawling all over this guy and he's like
okay well this guy obviously has
something to do with whatever the bad
thing is that's going to be happening so
probably i should start following that
guy like he does try to kind of hook up
with the police and everything like that
they're like look we don't you know
there's no evidence to tie him dude we
can't just like arrest him for shits and
giggles because a psychic said so you
know so he starts following him around
to see if he can get evidence and see
like what the [ __ ] it is that's uh going
to happen
so from then on
uh the movie is essentially just this
really really kind of a rollercoaster
ride of like twists and turns and like a
bunch of action set pieces like some
really cool special effects [ __ ] like
that because odd is sort of like racing
against time to figure out what this
disaster what this tragedy is that's
gonna happen who's involved in it how he
can prevent it and so it's that kind of
thing so the tone of this is very
similar i'm not the only person that
because i was watching it and i was like
oh this is like
the frighteners uh the peter jackson
movie from 1996 with michael j fox this
is very it's not
the same
but
tonally it's sort of similar so you know
what i mean where it's kind of like
it's kind of like a comedy like it has
funny [ __ ] in it and it's kind of like
lighthearted bits but then it's also
kind of like has a lot of dark uh you
know it has a lot of darkness to it as
well
and
not gonna lie i'm not gonna spoil it but
um the end of this uh i kind of thought
i was like oh my god is somebody like
cutting onions in this room right now i
was like you know what i mean the ending
of it is um
kind of a kind of a gut punch it was
like pretty pretty sad but yeah so if
you like the frighteners you would
probably like this as well i wouldn't
call it a horror comedy necessarily it
does have a lot of humor in it but
it also has a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] in
it you know it was like a lot of just
like the frighteners did and i kind of
feel like maybe that's why
this movie didn't do better even though
this is a really really good movie i
kind of feel like the same sort of thing
dogged the frighteners because people
were just kind of like well wait is this
well there's serial killers and there's
gore and it's scary but then it's like
funny and like people couldn't really
like
i don't know i i feel like people didn't
really like the tone as much i feel like
the frighteners is sort of got a
re-assessment like later on like when it
came out people were just like didn't
know what to make of it i guess but it
sort of got a cult following later on
and i kind of hope that that happens
with odd thomas as well because
you know as i said i can see it's things
that are like horror movies that are
like this that have a tone like this are
a hard sell because it's not an overt
horror comedy
but it's not like an overt horror movie
either it's sort of like a paranormal
what i call it like a paranormal action
horror kind of with some comedic
elements like a dark comedy because i
mean there is like some gory [ __ ] in
this but it's funny too but like a black
humor so it's hard to kind of square but
like i said if you like the frighteners
then you would probably like this as
well because the tone of it is uh pretty
similar
now uh as i said it's kind of
[ __ ] disgraceful
that
this movie just didn't find an audience
and it was just financially tanked and
that was
shitty also obviously it's terrible and
heartbreaking that anton yelchin died so
young um just when he was getting ready
to be a big star
i kind of feel like had circumstances
been different
this would have been
a really good first movie and you could
kind of tell i don't i don't want to say
at the end of this they were like
setting it up like for a series or for a
sequel or whatever but had they wanted
to go in that direction they could have
because it was kind of left open
and as i said the book
uh had six sequels and a bunch of and
some prequels and stuff as well so they
absolutely could have made like a
franchise out of this which i totally
would have watched because cause odd
thomas was such a great
character and you could just show him
having like different adventures you
know seeing ghosts and he could like
solve mysteries and stuff like that that
would be like really kick ass
but of course uh because this movie
didn't do very well and unfortunately
because anton nielsen died and i don't
i really don't think i could see anyone
else in that role i mean he was kind of
like perfectly cast in that role because
he was just kind of you bought that he
could
you know sort of fight and be tough and
everything like that but he was also
like really sweet and really vulnerable
and
you know he was just like a genuinely
good person and i think he sold that
really well
so unfortunately you know he's you know
he's passed away now so you know they're
they're not gonna be able to do that but
i i do really think he was perfectly
cast in this movie and
you know it's
it's just it's really a shame and i hate
when that happens like when there's such
a good movie like this and like not a
lot of people have seen it but
uh as i said if you're really into
these kind of like paranormal action
type uh things maybe like the
frighteners as i mentioned then probably
you would dig this and i would recommend
checking it out because it really does
need more love i think um i believe it's
on amazon prime at least as of this
recording and it might be some other
streaming services as well so go check
it out uh or if you've seen it let me
know what you think about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys on
the next one bye